the Brazen and brutal attack on the
husband of house Speaker Nancy Pelosi
Paul pelusi underwent surgery to repair
a skull fracture after he was beaten
with a hammer inside a San Francisco
home Friday doctors say they expect the
82 year old to make a full recovery a
suspect is in custody charged with
attempted murder assault with a deadly
weapon burglary and elder abuse speaker
Pelosi was not at home at the time of
the attack
Christina rafini is at the Capitol with
the very latest Christina good morning
good morning Michelle law enforcement
sources tell CBS News the Intruder
shouted where's Nancy and plan to detain
Paul Pelosi until the speaker got home
now late yesterday police wouldn't
comment on a motive but said the attack
was not random it was targeted and it
was wrong
Broadway Across the Scott and Normandy
with the attacker in the house police
say Paul Pelosi was able to make an open
Line 9-1-1 call around 2 A.M on Friday
he was the caller dispatch kind of took
it from there and read between the lines
on the Call Federal sources told CBS
News the dispatcher could hear what
sounded like someone being threatened in
the background and since a high priority
alert to law enforcement her actions in
my opinion resulted in both a higher
priority dispatch and a faster police
response
I think this was life-saving arriving on
scene police say they saw signs of
forced entry including broken glass our
officers observed mitz Pelosi and the
suspect both holding a hammer the
suspect pulled the hammer away from Miss
Pelosi and violently assaulted him with
it the suspect
rolled David Wayne depap was immediately
apprehended by police and is facing
multiple felony charges assault with a
deadly weapon elder abuse burglary a CBS
News Review of suspected social media
post by David depap shows him spreading
conspiracy theories about Holocaust
denial pedophiles in the government and
claims that Democratic officials run
child sex rings
speaker Pelosi who was in Washington DC
at the time of the attack rushed to the
San Francisco hospital where her
82-year-old husband underwent successful
surgery to repair a skull fracture and
serious injuries to his right arm and
hands according to her office but the
break-in raises concerns about the
safety members of Congress and their
families enough is enough is enough
campaigning in Philadelphia last night
President Biden condemned the attack
every person of good conscience
needs to clearly and unambiguously
stand up against the violence Senate
minority leader Mitch McConnell wrote he
was quote horrified and disgusted by
reports of the incident and Texas
Republican Ted Cruz a longtime critic of
Pelosi tweeted we can have our political
differences but violence is always wrong
and unacceptable
but yesterday just days before the
midterm election the Department of
Homeland Security issued a new bulletin
warning of a heightened threat towards
candidates running for public office
elected officials and election workers
and said some violent extremists might
be motivated by differing perceptions of
issues like government overreach
Firearms regulation and immigration
policy issues that have been front and
center in the run-up to November there's
no room for violence anywhere but we're
going to send her back to be with him in
California that's what we're going to go
do
now just to clarify it's Capitol Police
not the San Francisco police or the
Secret Service that's responsible for
the speaker's security as well as that
for other members of Congress and law
enforcement tells us they do not have
the resources nor is it standard
protocol for them to protect lawmakers
families Around the Clock Jeff
just awful details Christina thank you
very much